a estas alturas de nuestra vida que ya
sabemos que es una ecuación diferencial
ya estamos listos para este vídeo en
este vídeo vamos a ver ecuaciones
diferenciales separables y vamos a
ocupar mucho conocimiento del cálculo
tanto del cálculo integral como del
cálculo diferencial la idea que está
inmiscuida detrás de este método es
dejar de un lado de la ecuación todo lo
que depende de x y dejar del otro del
lado de la ecuación todo lo que depende
de iu y después integrar ambas partes en
esta ocasión que vamos a ver ecuaciones
diferenciales separables la idea también
va a ser hacer un par de ejercicios para
que ustedes creen en esta intuición de
cómo se resuelven este tipo de
cuestiones diferenciales el primer
ejercicio va a ser el siguiente voy a
tomar la derivada de jake con respecto a
x igualada a una función que dependa
tanto de x como dije en este caso voy a
tomar la función x cuadrada entre 1 - y
el cuadrado y ya que tenemos nuestra
ecuación diferencial ahora vamos a
hacernos unas preguntas lo primero que
quiero saber es esta ecuación es el
primer orden o de que órdenes
pues la respuesta es que en efecto es el
primer orden y eso va a ser debido a que
solamente tenemos la primera derivada
con respecto a x si tuviéramos la
segunda derivada la tercera derivada o
derivadas parciales serían de un orden
distinto ahora la segunda pregunta que
yo quiero hacerles es dado que ya
tenemos terminologías de ecuaciones
diferenciales entonces yo me puedo
preguntar si esta ecuación diferencial
es lineal o no lineal en un principio no
podría contestar es lineal sale es
lineal pero no es lineal porque
recuerden que es una función que depende
de x y si nosotros pasamos 1 - de
cuadrada del otro lado pues nos va a
quedar claramente que esta ecuación no
es lineal
vamos a hacerlo 1 - cuadrada que va a
multiplicar lo estoy pasando todo del
otro lado pues multiplica la derivada de
ella con respecto a x y esto va a ser
igual a x cuadrada y aquí ya se nota
claramente que esta ecuación no es señal
debido a que es una función de x y ya
está multiplicada por su primer derivada
entonces por lo que nosotros teníamos
entendido esto
es una ecuación diferencial lineal
recuerden cuál era la definición de una
ecuación diferencial lineal de hecho
acabamos de matar dos pájaros de un
tiro' pues al haber yo he pasado el 1 -
cuadrado del otro lado de la ecuación es
mi primer paso para resolver por el
método de separación de variables
recuerden que la idea original es dejar
todo lo que tenga que ver con que de un
lado de la ecuación y dejar todo lo que
tenga que ver con x del otro lado de la
ecuación entonces de aquí y puedo hacer
una trampita puedo decir que esto es 1
cuadrada que multiplica a la diferencia
del día y esto es igual a x cuadrada que
multiplica la diferencial de x es decir
la derivada de ella con respecto a x la
estoy separando y voy a pasar del otro
lado lo que tiene que ver con de iu y es
con este paso que hemos logrado lo que
hemos querido puesto que ya podemos
integrar tanto de un lado como de otro
bien encontremos las primitivas
es decir voy a integrar tanto de un lado
derecho como del lado izquierdo entonces
si yo integro 1 - cuadrada diferencial
de y esto ya lo sabemos hacer pues la
integral de esto
es la integral de 1 y la integral de
menor y cuadrada de que es pues menos 10
cúbica entre tres son las integrales
sencillas que hemos visto toda la vida y
a esto le tenemos que sumar una
constante
le voy a sumar una constante y le voy a
cambiar el color rojo para que se den
cuenta que esta constante es la que me
sale al integrar la parte izquierda de
mi ecuación diferencial es decir la
parte que dependía de ella bien esto es
por una parte pero por la otra parte
tenemos la integral de x cuadrada de x
entonces pues también lo podemos hacer
realmente es un integral muy sencilla de
resolver la integral de x cuadrada pues
es x cúbica entre 3 déjenme anotarlo
porque es lo único que tenemos que
integrar de este lado y agregarle una
constante del lado derecho esta
constante le voy a poner constante sub
índice x debido a que es la constante
que me salió al haber hecho la
integración sobre x realmente al final
me voy a quedar solamente con una
constante perdón que les cuente el final
de la película pero pues al operar una
constante con otra constante pues no va
a dar de resultado otra constante
vamos a hacerlo con calma y -10 pública
entre 3 va a ser igual a pues x cúbica
entre 3 y que estoy haciendo con las
constantes pues las voy a apuntar en una
única constante esta constante va a ser
la constante x menos la constante y pero
si yo tengo una constante que me salió
de integrar la parte de xy yo tengo una
constante que nos salió de integrar la
parte d i y la resto pues al final es
una constante un número menos otro
número pues es un número y de hecho yo
puedo escribir esta solución de una
manera un poco más elegante o tal vez un
poco más coqueta fíjense todo está
dividido entre tres entonces qué pasa se
multiplicó ambos lados de la ecuación
por tres pues me queda 13 menos bien
cúbica igual a equis cúbica más y pues
es 13 pero como se es una constante
arbitraria entonces 3 x c pues también
es una constante entonces no es
necesario escribir 13 solamente con que
pongamos c es más que suficiente
y bueno aquí está nuestra solución
general de esta ecuación diferencial a
muchas personas les gusta escribir de
una manera distinta muchas personas lo
que prefieren ver es una familia de
soluciones o de curvas es decir lo que
escriben es 37 cúbica - x cúbica igual a
una constante dicho de otra manera es
una función implícita implícita porque
esperar de aquí ayer como función de x
no se ve nada sencillo otra cosa que
quiero hacer notar es que esta es una
familia de curvas o una familia de
soluciones debido a que si yo cambio
enlace o dicho de otra manera yo vario
la cee y le pongo distintos valores voy
a obtener funciones implícitas distintas
pero cada una de estas funciones va a
ser solución de mi ecuación diferencial
de variables separables aquí radica la
complejidad de la cen y ya para
finalizar este ejercicio me gustaría
contarles que nosotros podemos
determinar la cee si nosotros damos unas
condiciones iniciales podríamos saber el
valor de c
por ejemplo es decir que para x igualdad
todos
al de 3 y así poder sacar nuestra sed de
hecho en nuestro siguiente ejemplo vamos
a tomar una ecuación diferencial que
tiene una condición inicial para poder
así determinar nuestra constante
este segundo ejemplo me va a quedar de
esta manera la derivada de ya con
respecto a x es igual a tres veces x
cuadrada más 4 veces x ya esto le voy a
sumar 2 y lo voy a dividir todo entre 2
que multiplica a que menos uno este 2
multiplicar tanto la aie como al menos 1
y ahora vamos a darle también
condiciones iniciales voy a decir que ya
de 0 es igual a menos 1 que quiere decir
esto que cuando nosotros resolvamos
nuestra ecuación diferencial y ya
tengamos allí con respecto a x cada vez
que yo vea a x voy a poner 0 y cada vez
que veáis que voy a poner menos 1 y con
estos valores pueden obtener la
constante de integración este ejercicio
es muy parecido al ejercicio pasado así
que voy a pasar el 2 que multiplica el
día menos uno del otro lado de la
ecuación diferencial
2 que multiplica menos 1 por la derivada
de con respecto a x es igual a 3x
cuadrada más 4x más 2 antes de integrar
se me ocurre multiplicar el 2 por la
yale por el menos uno voy a obtener 2 10
menos dos que multiplica a su vez de que
ya estoy separando la derivada de con
respecto a x y del otro lado me va a
quedar 3x cuadrada más 4 x más 2 que
multiplica a de x con esto ya obtuve lo
que quería dejar de un lado de la
ecuación todo lo que tenga que ver con
dejar del otro lado de la ecuación todo
lo que tienen que ver con x llevas
integramos magenta es decir con color
más gente vamos a hacer la integral y
sacar las primitivas ya tenemos la
solución de esta ecuación diferencial la
integral de dos pues ese cuadrado y la
integral de menos 2 es 2 y ésta va a ser
igual al integral del otro lado
integrando el otro lado quienes la
integran de 3x cuadrada pues es x cómica
y la integral de 4x es 2x cuadrada y la
de 22 x y para terminar de integrar
solamente de este lado de la ecuación
le voy a agregar
instante ya no es necesario que les
explique por lo que vimos en el
ejercicio pasado porque solamente pongo
una constante esta constante tiene que
ver con las dos constantes de integral
tanto de un lado como de otro ahora voy
a usar las condiciones iniciales para
determinar esta constante y si yo tengo
que que de cero es igual a menos uno
pues cada vez que vea yo le voy a poner
menos uno entonces me va a quedar menos
uno elevado al cuadrado menos dos x
menos uno y del otro lado de la ecuación
me queda que es igual a cero al cubo más
2% al cuadrado más dos por cero más mi
constante pero todo esto de acá todo
esto es cero entonces lo voy a tachar y
ahora si menos uno al cuadrado es uno y
menos dos por menos uno es más dos y
esto es igual a la constante o dicho de
otra manera pues la constante es igual a
donde más 2 que es 3 una vez que ya
obtuve mi constante ahora se puede
reescribir mi solución general y
sustituir a mi constante me va a quedar
que esto es cuadrada minutos
lo voy a escribir de verde
y esto va a ser igual a equis cúbica 2x
cuadrada más 2x más mi constante que
vale 3 ya tengo mi solución particular
porque ya tengo yo el valor de mi
constante pero ya se dieron cuenta creo
que esta vez sí puedo despejada y si yo
completo el binomio al cuadrado perfecto
del lado izquierdo puedo despejar ayer
miren
voy a sumarle uno a ambos lados de la
ecuación entonces voy a obtener que ya
cuadrada menos dos más uno es igual a
equis cúbica más 2x cuadrada más 2x más
3 más 14 y esto lo hago porque yo puedo
escribir ya cuadrada menos 2 yemas uno
como un binomio cuadrado perfecto el
cual me va a quedar bien menos 1 todo
elevado al cuadrado y esto es igual a
equis cúbica más 2 x cuadrada más 12 x
más 4
y yo puedo pasar del otro lado de una
vez mi cuadrado entonces voy a obtener
que estos más o menos la raíz cuadrada
de x cúbica más 2 x cuadrada más 2 x más
4 recuerdan que sacar una raíz cuadrada
ponemos más menos y ahora voy a pasar el
1 sumando que va a ser igual a 1 más
menos la raíz cuadrada de x cúbica 2x
cuadrada más 2 x + 4 ya obtuve por fin
despejada es decir esta es una función
explícita una función que depende de x
pero nunca hay que olvidar las
condiciones iniciales las condiciones
esenciales realmente me dicen mucho yo
quiero que esta función me cumpla mis
condiciones iniciales y voy a ver si
realmente tienen que ser más menos en
que va a ser igual a 1 + menos y como el
x valía cero pues todo esto es cero
solamente nos queda el 4 o sea que es
igual a más 1 más menos 2
y que esto nos tenía que dar menos 1 y
esto nos da menos 1 solamente cuando es
menos ya ves no era más menos solamente
es menos voy a cancelar aquí el más y
voy a cancelar también de aquí el más y
de aquí el más y de aquí en más para que
me cumpla mi condición inicial nunca hay
que olvidar las condiciones iniciales y
es así como obtenemos ya nuestra función
que depende solamente de equis pero
estamos corriendo en el tiempo ya
tenemos muy poco tiempo así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo